A club of nine people wants
to choose a board of three
officers, President, Vice
President, and Secretary.
Assuming the officers are chosen
at random, what is the
probability that the officers
are Marcia for president,
Sabita for Vice President,
and Robert for Secretary?
So to think about the
probability of Marcia-- so let
me write this-- President is
equal to Marcia, or Vice
President is equal
to Sabita, and
Secretary is equal to Robert.
This, right here, is one
possible outcome,
one specific outcome.
So it's one outcome out of the
total number of outcomes, over
the total number of
possibilities.
Now what is the total number
of possibilities?
Well to think about that, let's
just think about the
three positions.
You have President, you
have Vice President,
and you have Secretary.
Now let's just assume that we're
going to fill the slot
of President first. We don't
have to do President first,
but we're just going
to pick here.
So if we're just picking
President first, we haven't
assigned anyone to any officers
just yet, so we have
nine people to choose from.
So there are nine possibilities
here.
Now, when we go to selecting our
Vice President, we would
have already assigned one
person to the President.
So we only have eight
people to pick from.
And when we assign our
Secretary, we would've already
assigned our President and Vice
President, so we're only
going to have seven people
to pick from.
So the total permutations here
or the total number of
possibilities, or the total
number of ways, to pick
President, Vice President, and
Secretary from nine people, is
going to be 9 times 8 times 7.
Which is, let's see,
9 times 8 is 72.
72 times 7, 2 times 7 is 14, 7
times 7 is 49 plus 1 is 50.
So there's 504 possibilities.
So to answer the question, the
probability of Marcia being
President, Sabita being Vice
President, and Robert being
Secretary is 1 over the total
number of possibilities, which
is 1 over 504.
That's the probability.